in grapevine they are relying on
emergency generators for
electricity like many towns in texas the
extreme weather
has caused a wave of power outages many
people
are cold and helpless they come to this
impromptu emergency shelter set up in a
leisure center
a refuge from the plummeting temperature
we meet charles tired but relieved to be
here
i don't think i could have stayed in
there all night so
i think i did the right thing by coming
up into this warming station here at
least
to let me let me live another day you
know if you would have done it if you
stayed up
probably so yeah in another room cherie
and her daughter zoe
after a night sleeping here they've
managed to find a hotel to move to
it's way more assuring but i mean here
they were really accommodating everybody
was really nice they made sure
all of us had but we needed it they gave
us you know hot water
if we needed it we had coffee all night
they gave us extra blankets so
it's been you know rough but they're
doing what they can and they've been
phenomenal
but not everyone is so lucky hotel rooms
are rare and expensive in texas now
we're with belinda as she tries to find
somewhere warm for the night
hi um i'm hoping that you had rooms
available tonight
okay you don't want to travel 50 miles
do you no okay
thank you anyway okay
bye-bye and how many so are you
available do you have any rooms
available tomorrow
oh no night nothing available okay all
right thank you
we're not uh used to having this uh you
know such an unavailability but
all around us people whose lives have
been thrown into chaos
by the weather but there's also
phlegmatism here
euler will celebrate her 95th birthday
on sunday
listen i went through the depression i
went through all the wars
i can get through this i can get through
this
it is the same story across this huge
state
texas is nearly three times bigger than
the uk and much of it
has been struck down and brought to a
halt by the effects of
arctic conditions this is the texan town
of uless and just around here 10
000 households woke up with no
electricity
and no heating they were told to keep
the shutters closed to keep the heat in
and
as you can see the roads are very very
quiet now the electricity has returned
sporadically but any optimism has been
tempered by the knowledge
that another snowstorm is forecast to
arrive in the coming hours
texas has wealth and resources but it is
struggling to cope with the crisis
and nobody knows if there's worse to
come adam parsons sky news
tarrant county texas